[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast if
you'd take a second and hit the
Subscribe button I would really
appreciate it today on the show is uh
Robert Gilbert this is his second
appearance now but after he came on last
time I just there's just so many aspects
that we needed to cover still so we
actually started talking about stem
cells exomes PRP and anti-aging things
which then led into a a very quick
highlevel understanding of biogeometry
which is is one of the things that he
teaches and we also delved into what I
really wanted to talk to him about which
was Rosicrucianism so he goes into the
history of it and where it came from and
really covered such a wide base of the
Integrity of it and what what it is to
be in the practice when we go into these
practices and learn Beyond where we're
at we're really just trying to figure
out how can we just be happier more of
the time how can we have more joy in our
life how can we understand not only
ourselves but others better why it is so
needed right now and what our potential
really is as human beings and the world
that we live in if you've been following
me a while you know that I've been
drinking ag1 all year no matter where I
go or what I do if I'm at the racetrack
if I'm in Europe for six weeks no matter
what I'm drinking ag1 every single
morning when I started drinking ag1
daily what I noticed was that my gut
health improved I could eat so many
different foods without it bothering me
my skin has gotten better my hair is
healthier so many functions that
everybody wants to get better got better
it's so awesome and I've been bragging
about it so much that my friends and my
family have also started taking it and
they love it as well ag1 is the
supplement that I trust to support my
body's daily needs and that's why we
have been partners for so long if you
want to take take ownership of your
health it starts with ag1 try ag1 and
get a free one-year supply of vitamin D3
K2 plus five free ag1 travel packs with
your first purchase go to drink a1.com
pretty intense that's drink a1.com
pretty intense check it out how have you
been I've been great uh things have been
very exciting we're currently working on
bringing Dr Ibraham kareim the founder
of biogeometry back to North America for
the first time in many years to give
presentations on his latest research and
uh a lot of projects going on oh that's
a big deal that reminds me when I was in
in Europe this summer I spent part of
the trip with one of my girlfriends who
loves to learn new spiritual practices
of all kinds but one of them that she
started doing was biogeometry oh
fantastic your course on biogeometry and
so she had the book and she was going
through the level one and we did some
bio feedback stuff for a couple of
people and I found it super cool and
super fascinating so that's pretty
exciting that Dr isn't it Dr Kem yes
yeah that he is coming to the states yes
uh he's going to be coming in March to
present uh just a short presentation at
the Gaia conference in Boulder but uh
then we're having him for a evening
Public Presentation in before that in
March and Then followed by a three-day
intensive with new information he hasn't
given out before uh for people that have
been trained in biogeometry and we're
expecting people from all all over the
world to come here to Las Vegas for that
so we're really excited about it what
level do you have to be at to be able to
be a part of his event you'll need to
have completed the foundation and
advanced trainings which can both be
done online okay uh before that time in
March how old is he now I'm not sure I
think he must be in his later 70s but
I'm I'm not certain later 70s or 322
we're not really
sure yeah he's an old soul so didn't
people used to live a really really
really long time according to Old
scripture According to some old
scriptures yeah people lived a very long
time even some of the modern dsts say
that uh you know they have relatives who
are like 140 so you know apparently it's
quite possible do you think that that's
true that they Liv that old uh I think
it's certainly true for the DST today
that they they live to these well over a
hundred ages using their DST internal
Alchemy in the ancient world I certainly
think many things were possible
according to what's often referred to as
the secret Doctrine based on baty's work
like the ancient knowledge
uh there are ways in earlier times when
people's internal energy configuration
in the body was quite different than
today uh for people to have expanded
lifetimes and I've actually been doing
research recently with uh the latest
developments in stem cell exosomes these
types of things which is developing very
quickly and the public doesn't really
know everything that's happening with it
but it's absolutely amazing what's being
done with the stem cell derived
technology and I think it's going to
lead to a a real revolution in health
care and particularly in
longevity so just recently myself and
the director of the vesa Institute
Jennifer Barnes went to a clinic in Utah
which does the one of the most
comprehensive full body stem cell
Rejuvenation things in the world it
previously been covered by Ben
Greenfield oh yeah and uh yeah by the
fellow that does the bulletproof podcast
and these things they've done it Dave
and and Dave did it like three times
yeah I went down to Costa Rica with Dave
and did stem cells um earlier this year
so I've done exomes I've done stem cells
they were not mine though so I really I
I didn't think we'd get in this little
spot we're in but I'm so fascinated what
you have learned about this well it
seems that you know it's kind of the
Wild West in the US the although the FDA
FDA is somewhat controlling with it
there is a lot of innovation being done
by different researchers and they have
very very different approaches so one of
the things it's hard to get information
on you kind of have to do your own
research and follow up with people I
don't know any textual sources that go
into it is the different approaches that
different clinics are taking and uh they
can have very different viewpoints on
how to approach this kind of thing MH
but again the one that we just did in
Utah is supposed to be one of the most
comprehensive in the world where you get
every joint in the body injected as well
as cosmetic and sexual injections it's
suppos to be over 100 injections and you
have to be under IV sedation to do it
because it takes a prolong period of
time but you know they've had remarkable
results again Dave's done that
particular one uh three times himself
already MH and I just found out
yesterday meeting with a stem cell
Clinic here in Las Vegas that they've
been working on a method where using a
modification of CPAP machines not for
how CPAP machines are normally used but
to be able to deliver various types of
pharmaceuticals or things directly into
the
lungs that they found that they can
rejuvenate lung tissue so people with
like COPD long-term lung damage these
types of of things are getting reversals
from getting the exosomes put through
the CPAP machine directly into the lungs
themselves and uh it's just fascinating
to see everything that's going on with
the
field gosh yeah yeah I've been I work
with various different companies that
develop devices that do like the highest
grade PRP which is another sort of
aspect they usually say to to pair PRP
and stem cells together a lot of times
when they're doing joints Orthopedic
like injections as well as another
company that I work with that does more
cosmetic like procedures with equipment
they use like the highest grade way of
extracting the PRP another oh that's the
exome sorry that's the PRP the other one
is exosomes because there's a certain
amount of bioavailability that the
exosomes can have and there are many
companies that actually don't have
really any viable exosomes in the
product and so this is sort of like a
very high level certification that the
exosomes are that there's a high amount
of available exosomes to actually be
delivered so wow do you think that the
Ancients had this sort of technology or
is this sort of modern-day humans that
are coming up with new ways of longevity
I think this is a a modern development
because we're so based today on physical
and chemical analysis but in ancient
times there was much more based on
energetic analysis and so they would be
using methods that I'm sure if we
studied them today in our modern
methodology we would see that what's
happening is that their energetic
methods are simply a different route to
be able to activate the stem cells and
exosomes and these different types of
natural substances in the body so I was
very impressed with the book uh that is
called the spark in the machine
uh in which a person did quite a bit of
research uh that uh in this particular
text they describe how you can find a
very clean relationship a very clear
relationship between the acupuncture
points in the body and the branching
points for stem cell differentiation in
the body and basically makes the uh the
statement that the acupuncture Meridian
system and the acupuncture point system
are actually the controllers for all
stem cell activity in the body and
actually is what gives rise to the
differentiated body parts that we have
which I find very fascinating and
similarly a conclusion very close of
that has been reached by my friend Dr
Jerry tenant who developed uh the series
of books on healing is voltage and in
his work in Dallas he's also come to the
conclusion that the the Meridian system
is the a master controller of all of the
voltage gates in the human body that
lead to all the Rejuvenation and
regeneration and that would also then
apply although that's not his focus on
stem cells and things of that kind so I
think the thing we're going to be
finding in the very near future is an
incredible overlap between these more
ancient Sciences like the dowst
knowledge of internal Alchemy and the
human internal energy system with the
meridians acupuncture points Etc and
what we found through empirical
discoveries in the last 30 years having
to do with the activation and direction
of stem cells exosomes injection of PRP
and things of that
kind wow oh another thing that just came
to mind when you said that is that one
of these companies I work with that does
not only PRP but stem cells as well and
they do like the sort of threading har
to harvest the stem cells from the bone
from inside the bone we were talking
about where you get them from where you
get the stem cells from and uh there is
a very big difference between different
parts of the body and the quality or the
composition of the stem cells that you
take it from basically like lower back
on the top of the hip there and that's
the best place to take the take stem
cells from not sort of like the arm or
the thigh or the any anywhere else but
like but back of the hip isn't that
fascinating that's absolutely
fascinating I hadn't heard that before
that the back of the hip has the best
stem cells to harvest in the body that's
quite that's quite amazing you know the
whole stem cell revolution in the US got
catalyzed as they were able to move from
fetally derived stem cells to using
umbilical cord derived and I understand
that there's much more advanced work
being done and permitted in Europe than
in the US today having to do with much
of this technology and how they're able
to differentiate the stem cells and come
up with the highest quality stem cells
to inject into the body so I think that
that's one of the cutting edges of this
whole field right now is to get more
clarity about the different quality
types of stem cells exosomes things of
this kind uh which I think is going to
add a tremendous amount to the field
it's one of those things that when you
see what's actually happening with
people who are getting some of these
treatments that the general knows
nothing about that it's just absolutely
revolutionary well look at Dave I mean
we're talking about Dave it's Dave
asprey if you look back at old videos
and pictures of him to where he is now
it's really amazing and and this is only
just this is just sort of anecdotal in
my life but people are like wow you look
great like what are you doing and I'm
like I guess I got to give credit to the
stem cells and the exosomes and all the
things um so I think because I've been
doing it probably long enough for it to
have sort of at least a wave of an
effect after a year year and a half that
maybe it's really working I I really do
think that that's probably the case you
do look very radiant and I I do believe
that the sem cell technology is one of
the most powerful things that we can can
use today for regeneration I really want
to talk about the rosac crucian order
and the rosac crism and and that whole I
I I want I I think we could take another
moment with biogeometry and just sort of
touch on that because of the event that
you have coming and and also just
because we're talking so much about stem
cells and and exomes and and and the way
that the body is informed to heal or
rejuvenate so maybe go into sort of like
a little bit of a overview of of
biogeometry and like what people would
learn and what what what it actually is
because just as sort of my experience
with my friend who's taking the course
is that that you know we're looking
through the book and doing the biof
feedback with for someone to figure out
what areas of the body they need help
and there are unique very interesting
symbols that correlate with all the
different parts and aspects of the body
and healing and so I found that
incredibly fascinating then of course
sent the pictures to people that we did
it for for them to look over themselves
to trace with their eyes as well as
where and have on them so that's again
just my own small experience with it um
just to kind of give people a taste of
and also confuse them a little to make
them curious like what the hell are you
talking about so um I'd love to hear
from your perspective what the overview
of biogeometry and learning about it
looks like great thank you so I first
met Dr Kareem around the year 2000 when
he began to come to the United States to
teach some courses in Florida and I was
absolutely Amazed by what he was doing
and what he had developed he really had
rediscovered from a modern perspective
many of the Lost secrets of the ancient
Egyptian temple science he will often
refer to biogeometry as being Nature's
Own design language of shape sound color
motion angle
proportion the way that all of these
natural qualities actually control and
direct the life forces in every living
being on the planet and as an architect
what he's been able to develop is an
understanding of the way that shape
information is able to generate
vibrational forces that affect living
beings at both Consciousness and energy
levels and he's developed this very very
far with very original research one
aspect of this is what you were
describing as the types of forms or
shapes that we're using and one aspect
of this is what's called biog
geometrical shapes so something like a
what we refer to as a 45 degree emitter
a a backing of a certain length with two
arms coming off of a certain length at a
45 degree angle will create a
concentration of a specific vibrational
power between them that we refer to in
biogeometry as the bg3
which is essentially a concentration of
the universal harmonizing Force now this
is not something that's well understood
in many different Traditions many
Traditions focus on polarity energies
like Yin and yangong in Chinese medicine
and the way that we balance the two
polarities by adding the opposite
polarity if you have too much of the
other polarity so if A System's too cold
you add some warmth to it that type of
thing but there's actually a universal
harmonizing force that restores
everything to its balance point restores
it to the center it actually activates
the center of all biological functions
and all systems it's a amazing Discovery
by Dr kareim and you know again he's
very clear about the fact you know he
didn't invent it this is something that
nature uses all the time but he's simply
been able to clarify through his
research discoveries and what he finds
for these
different shap sounds colors motions
that are able to generate this
particular Force for practical
application then he was able to using
our radiesthesia methods derived from
the French research of the early
1900s which itself was derived from the
Egyptian knowledge and application of
vibrational science and vibrational
testing from thousands of years ago
radiesthesia is the ability to detect
subtle radiations or subtle vibrations
and so using the radiesthesia methods
that we teach in
biogeometry Dr kareim was able
to discover the actual movement pattern
of energy in the human body that
generates specific biological activities
so for example the way that energy moves
inside a person's liver may be one of
this isn't the actual number let's say a
dozen different energy movement patterns
every one of those energy movement
patterns generates a specific biological
activity and so basically we have the
concept of energy as a a proteus it is
the the Prima Materia it is the original
Source energy behind everything just
like stem cells can become anything
energy can become any anything right and
so just as the stem cells get programmed
in the body by particular triggers to
become certain things
again one of the things that's that's
discussed in the spark in the machine
book that's so fascinating so the
functions of the organs and systems in
the body is actually uh created by the
way that the energy moves in a specific
energy movement pattern so one of the
first things we learn in biogeometry is
not to think of shapes as some type of
finished static external form but rather
to think of them as Dynamic energy
movement patterns
and so it's the dynamic energy movement
that creates the effect so the shape is
like a circuit that the energy is moving
dynamically inside of and so all these
bio signatures are simply flattened
two-dimensional images of an original
three-dimensional energy movement
pattern that Dr kareim was able to trace
out using
radiesthesia and to then create the
mapping of hundreds of different what he
call bio signatures these energy
movement patterns in the body that
create biological effects and the ones
he's actually published many of these
bios signatures in his book on bios
signatures uh however in the classes
that we teach we're able to go much
further and we're able to teach people
how to energetically test any person for
which bios signatures they need at a
particular time to help reinforce that
energy movement pattern in the body that
creates that effect
and also how to uh be able to apply the
bio signatures in a variety of other
ways but that's only one small part of
the training there's so much to it in
understanding the actual science of
shape sound color motion uh that can be
practically applied whether it's for the
human being or in any type of design
work because a lot of the work that we
do is balancing the energy in homes
offices Etc in a very different approach
than is done by most other traditions
because we have the ability and we teach
people themselves to be able for the
rest of their lives directly detect all
these energy qualities whether it's in
their body or another person or in a
location again we make no medical claims
for it but it is something that is
absolutely remarkable and so we offer
both a foundation training that gives
people all the fundamental skills that
currently is being done as an online
class it takes place as something where
people have the material for around five
weeks and after the first couple of
weeks with the material we start having
once a week uh meetings for about four
hours where we can assist people with
any questions they have any issues with
doing the Hands-On testing and
applications and so there's three
meetings and successive weeks for that
and that's the foundation training and
then there's an advanced training that's
run along the same lines and so in the
question you had four to be able to work
with Dr Kareem when he comes on this
extremely rare uh trip to the United
States next march we're still working on
the exact dates we know it will be in
early March and it will most likely be
in Las Vegas there will be a a public
week uh or public evening where Dr
kareim will present for people who have
not taken the Advanced Training who want
to see him and hear from him live but
then there's going to be a three-day
intensive where he releases new
information because currently we have
the foundation and Advanced Training
after you do both of those online you
can work with him
directly and the the new material that's
coming out if people want to get a sense
of it it's extremely deep having to do
with how energy works through space and
time and can then be practically applied
in ways that are really mindblowing it
was recently published by Dr Kareem in
his book called hidden reality that was
published recently and is available on
Amazon on uh it is a remarkable text but
people want to start learning about his
work in addition to what's on the
internet I have videos about it on
YouTube he has some videos and also
there's his book that's back to a future
for mankind which is his introductory
book on biogeometry which is quite
remarkable in addition to the new book
which is extremely Advanced called
hidden
reality but when he comes in March to
Las Vegas and I'm so grateful to be able
to sponsor him for that myself and my
team here that uh he's going to be
offering not only new techniques and New
Concepts but also new tools uh the work
is developing very very quickly so to
get a chance to work with them directly
in North America is going to be a very
rare opportunity and really excited
about it
what is the most extreme way that you
could experience the highest use of it
if you were to like have you do you have
any stories is there anything where you
can share what sort of what this
technology what this what this knowledge
can do for
someone yes the the challenge of this is
following our principle of not making
any medical
claims which which is very very challeng
that box is smart but uh again possibly
what could be done well I I'll just give
you an example to avoid the medical
claims issue that uh of what happened
for me and so I had had a couple of very
severe car accidents uh before I met Dr
Kareem and one was extremely severe the
combined force of the two cars impacting
head-on including the car that I was in
the combined force of impact was around
160 miles an hour and uh had a lot of
damage to my neck and my
spine and I done a lot to to work on it
but it still was affecting my quality of
life extremely dramatically
and was a a major issue for me and so
when I met with Dr Kareem for the first
time in Florida one thing that he did is
he just had people come up and he would
test them for what bio signatures they
needed and he would engrave the correct
bio signature pattern on a piece of
metal that you could wear like a
medallion like today you can buy bio
signature medallions that don't have all
the bio signatures on them because there
a huge number but have like a a set of
some of the most important ones that
everyone needs my friend had a necklace
that had a a one symbol it was a it was
a symbol of sorts and she wore it that
was probably they have some bio
signature pendants that are of one
specific bio signature that does a
precise thing and then they have what we
call the bio signature Medallion which
has many different bio signatures on it
to get their composite effects at the
same time although again there're so
many bio signatures doesn't have all the
bio signatures they're ones that
everyone tends to need I'd be wearing
one like this big it'd be
like Dr Kareem has made some giant ones
before that he's uh like as big as like
a human body that he's like shown before
in a in a TV show that he did from Egypt
years ago these kinds of things but what
he did was he was able to find for me uh
particular bio signatures that I needed
for my my neck and my spine and he just
engraved it on this thing for for me to
wear and it really had an incred an
incredible effect for me it really gave
me my life back wow I was like this is
unbelievable that a particular again
people just think of it as like some
external shape but it's an energy
movement pattern that works in resonance
to activate that that movement pattern
in the human body and it was so dramatic
the effect I got from it that I began to
go to Every course he taught anywhere
that I could get to and I was so
dedicated to the work and I literally
transcribed all of his talks word for
word and then I reorganized it into a
more comprehensive uh linear system that
uh he invited me three years later to be
the first person outside of Egypt to
teach his work publicly and so that's
kind of how things develop there but it
was like that's an example of what's
possible with this again your mileage
may vary we don't make any claims for
what the effects of any of this will be
but uh this has happened for a lot of
people and in addition to that I've I've
had a lot of people get the results from
having their home and offices balanced
so that the detrimental vibrational
effects of all the things we're
surrounded by in our environment today
get modified and harmonized by
connecting it to this Universal
harmonizing energy or vibratory Force
we've gotten all kinds of remarkable
testimonials about the changes of
people's lives and wow things of this
kind uh again not making any medical
claims one of the first stories I heard
from someone I started teaching things
publicly was that they had a friend who
had had a motorcycle accident and they
were in a coma and they went to go see
them and they were hooked up to all this
different medical equipment well the
medical equipment is monitoring them and
these types of things but anything
that's electrical that's plugged into
the wall has a very specific vibrational
quality that's known technically as the
vertical wave of negative green it's too
complex to go into here but as part of
what we teach people about the different
vibrational qualities and biological
effects and so the person did exactly
what I taught them to do in the class
which is put specific bioge geometric
forms on all of the electronic equipment
in the space to take off the vibrational
quality of the vertical negative green
coming from the electrical circuits and
to replace it with this harmonizing
energetic force and the person said in
the class of the moment they put the
last correction on the last piece of
electronic equipment that was
surrounding their friend that at that
moment their friend came out of the coma
and so the theoretical basis behind that
again not making any medical claims just
theory is that by taking off the
suppressive effect of the
electromagnetic blanketing energies the
person was able to have their own life
forces recover to the point that they
could come back into Consciousness I
have three different EMF reducers in my
house spread out because they have a
range and that's one of the things that
I'm sensitive to is fields and energy I
don't feel people's emotions too much
I'm aware of them God I don't feel them
I aware of them but I feel frequency
very much so so is that something that
that would help reduce that negative
green negative uh that negative what do
you call it what's the the technical
name of it is negative green because on
a particular way of charting the
complete spectrum of the energy in a
circular format it's diametrically
opposite positive green what we think of
as the green color quality in the
qualitative scale of energies so they
the the French referred to it in the
early 1900s as negative green and they
said that it was actually known and used
by and counteracted by the ancient
Egyptians the Chinese Easter Island they
gave all types of examples of how they
worked with this energetic quality
because it can be used beneficially but
in the way it appears in like
electromagnetic circuits it's quite
harmful so the good thing about
biogeometry is it does have its own tool
line that you could use for balancing
these effects but in addition to that
it's not just a matter of selling you
another tool out of many different tools
on the market what we do in the
biogeometry training is we teach people
how to for the rest of their lives test
for themselves or others the specific
vibrational qualities coming from any
person place or thing and then when you
place a vibrational tool whether from
biog geometry or from any other source
onto the problem area you can now test
and know whether it's a it's actually
transforming the quality of energy or
not because there's many good
vibrational tools on the market today
and there's many that do absolutely
nothing and there's quite a few that
actually increase the toxic
energy and sometimes when I talk to the
people selling those tools they just
like say oh hold this you can feel the
energy and I'm like yeah I can feel the
energy but that energy is not a
beneficial energy but the people making
it don't know how to test and
differentiate energy qualities so one of
the things that's been huge breakthrough
with the biogeometry is we can teach
anybody how to be able to directly
detect the energetic quality coming from
anything so when you actually do like
let's say a Funway correction to a space
one thing that's been discovered is that
I love Funway it's a great system but
that if you try to apply the stuff that
was done a couple thousand years ago in
non-electromagnetic environments and you
think that's going to correct the
electromagnetic energy in the space we
can show you that it
doesn't but again this is something that
requires more discussion to really get
into the technical aspects of it because
it's a qualitative science and the
quantitative aspect of the
electromagnetic wave is still there
because the the trick of this what Dr
Kem had always explained to people when
he did things like balance the
electromagnetic fields for the whole
city of Hamburg Switzerland back around
2003 that's a baller move incredible
work that he's done he was able to
describe the way that you know if if I
was blocking the electromagnetic circuit
because people would like get an EMF
meter and say oh no the EMF is still
here look on the the meter he says yes
the EMF is still here because if I
blocked the EMF none of your
communication devices or energy devices
would be working and you wouldn't allow
me to do that we had to sever the
gordian knot like with Alexander the
Great to find a lateral thinking
solution to this which still has the
electromagnetic circuits in place
because otherwise our technology won't
work but to change the energetic quality
of them so that the effect on the human
mind and body is no longer destructive
but may even be beneficial because it is
actually increasing the broadcast of
this harmonizing Universal harmonizing
wave and so that's why we have to train
people in biogeometry to think in a
completely different way about it that
we're going to be testing and
transmuting the quality of energy on the
wave and it's not a matter of changing
the quantitative aspect of the wave
because we wouldn't be allowed to change
that so there's a there's quite a bit in
the training about how to do these
things on a practical level the rosac
crusan order this is something that
came across in an interview after an
interview it was with Ronda burn um from
the secret and she started talking about
it like after we were done with the
actual interview and I was fascinated
and it wasn't part of the interview but
she sort of had sort of said I can help
you out and like put you in touch with
someone and anyway I I just was too busy
to proceed with it but it's still been
in my mind and still been something very
I'm very curious about and I've reached
a point where I I feel like I know a lot
about myself there's always more to
learn but I want I want to be able to do
magic basically
yeah and something tells me if I were to
learn it that I would now be able to
practice what people would call Magic
and Magic being real but it's just
sounds not real to people because that's
the word we use for stuff we don't
understand yes so so uh I would really
like you to get slightly granular about
the process and and and what it takes
and and and even like I think we could
start with the history of it and you
know it's been it's known as like the
path of the mystics is this
correct yes uh so let me just preface
what I'm going to say by saying this is
my personal perspective this is my
experience and other people may see this
a bit differently I have my own
particular approach to it so take what I
say with as many grains of salt as you
like but if you look at it historically
the idea of the rosac crucians began
around the early 1600s as far as the
public is concerned MH where certain
books began to be published in Central
Europe that talked about the existence
of a rosac crucian order of Mystics of
adeps who were capable of all kinds of
remarkable things and doing it within
the context of the Christian
Tradition now we need to state that
because at that point particularly then
you know Europe was entirely Christian
other than you know the small groups of
Islamic and Jewish but you know the
control of Europe was completely
Christian tradition and so often we
think about adepts with highly Advanced
skills like even today we tend to think
about them as being Eastern adeps like
certain masters from India or China or
something like that the idea that there
were living amongst us these incredibly
Advanced Mystics with great Powers was
something that led to a tremendous
popular movement in Central Europe in
the 1600s of interest in what is the
rosar crucian tradition how do you find
these great Hidden Masters what can you
learn from them what is their method
these kinds of things and
so this then led to In Time the
development of public rosac crucian
organizations okay now in the creation
of public organizations rather than what
was happening behind the scenes which
I'll get to in just a moment with the
rosac crucian is that to create these
organizations they needed to have some
type of pattern to follow and so one
thing that happened that I personally
think is a bit of a mixed bag is that it
often would connect with uh
Freemasonry and so at the same time as
this is happening Freemasonry is
undergoing its own Revolution
historically for what was known as
operative Masons which are the people
that actually built the cathedrals if
you became a Freemason let's say back in
the 1400s you became an apprentice to
learn how to actually build Cathedrals
and things like that you were an
operative Mason okay it was based on
metaphysical principles and you learned
all kinds of amazing spiritual and
energetic things that the public would
never know uh but you are being trained
to be a a brick mason and to build
buildings a literal Mason but
particularly by the time we got to the
1700s this had changed and operative
masonry really was dying out and it
became what is known today as
speculative masonry and so speculative
masonry which is what most of all
Freemasonry today is is where you join
some fraternal organization and you go
through a number of rituals and rights
to get initiated into higher and higher
grades in and uh linear or degrees is it
still like degrees like is there 33
degrees in in some forms of masonry
there's 33 degrees and some forms is
over 90 there there's various forms were
developed it's gonna take a while yes
exactly or not this interview but I'm
saying like to be a 90 degree Mason oh
boy yeah but those forums the 90 the 90
plus degree forums are not very popular
today it's hard to find those forums the
33 degree is the main one that that that
dominated but the
idea with this is that uh you would join
this organization and you would work
your way through these grades through
these degrees over a period of years
until you reach the highest level of
initiation
Etc now I I have to State my own bias
upfront that I kind of follow the
pathway of the you know the joke made by
Woody Allen years ago that I wouldn't
want to join any organization that would
have someone like me for a member so my
basic approach to this is I'm not really
so much of an organization follower yeah
and I do think that's a bit of the the
ethic of our age that uh as we develop
public rosac Cru and organizations many
of them began to take on these types of
masonic
organizational Fabrics
that that the challenge of it is people
can get caught up in the working through
the actual politics of this organization
of human beings and I have no interest
in that whatsoever I mean less than zero
so uh it almost starts feeling like
organized religion or something where
there's probably all rooted in a great
start and then man gets a hold of it and
politics come in and money and power and
and ego and I'm a higher degree than you
and you have to do this and that again
no appeal to me for that and if people
choose to to work within Masonic or
rosac crucian external organizations
that's fine now in the United States
some of the largest organizations are
quite old things like AMC and rosean
fellowship they're quite old at this
point people want to work in those
Frameworks and that's what helps them to
have something that is that clearly
delineated and that you can work through
with the external help of other people
great those forums still exist and you
can do that uh that's not my my
orientation and I'm not going to be
teaching people about that my
orientation has always been toward what
the rosac crusan organization was
originally and that was it wasn't part
of an
external physical
organization it was as was discussed in
the early text in the 1600s it was a
group of people that had Direct
spiritual connection to the beings
behind the rosar crucian tradition so
let's clarify for everybody right now
something that's extremely fundamental
but not often spoken
of and this is a definition coming from
a person I learned a lot from Dr Samuel
sagon a French Medical Doctor Who later
became a translator of Sanskrit texts
into
French uh back in the 80s who developed
a school called the Clair Vision school
that I trained with in Sydney Australia
for a time and he had this he had many
brilliant summarizations of esoteric
realities and one of Sagan's ideas with
the Clair Vision school is that whenever
we talk about a spiritual tradition
you're talking about a group of human
beings with a group of non-physical
Spiritual Beings that are working
together for a particular goal for a
particular pathway now as you drill down
deeper into this one of the things that
you find that this group of Spiritual
Beings behind that tradition so there's
a group of beings behind the Buddhist
tradition behind the DS tradition behind
the Christian tradition whatever it is
in some cases there's overlaps that gets
a little complex but that group of
beings is working with human beings and
one of the things that's happening
invisibly if you're choosing to train in
let's say the Buddhist system versus the
DST versus the Christian Etc is that the
training systems are having the basic
cause and effect result that what you're
doing with your mind in the spiritual
practices what you're doing with your
energy in the spiritual practices is
structuring your energy body structuring
your subtle bodies into very literal
geometric
formations that are going to give you
certain citas or Powers SAS is the term
coming from the hamalian tradition and
so the there's an infinite number of
spiritual practices that we could do and
one of the things that's happened in
recent times I often refer to as our
modern blessing and a curse which is
that we have access to more incredible
deep spiritual information than we've
ever had in any other time in recorded
human history like things that used to
be highly secret you can now buy the
information about it for 1695 in a
paperback book like that's what happened
in the DST internal Alchemy Traditions
so it's unbelievable that's only
happened in the last 40 years okay so
that's a great blessing that we get
access to all this previously hidden
information the curse of it is that a
lot of people don't have the the
contextual background to be able to
differentiate and sort through the flood
of information from all these sources
which sometimes comes out in a somewhat
twisted uh way that doesn't make it
actually clear what the real thing is uh
to put all these fragments that have
come out from all these Traditions into
some workable format that actually lead
to a tangible result in the structuring
of the subtle bodies and the core
Spiritual Development of the person in a
way that we can take through the gate of
death and into the subsequent
incarnations that's really the key thing
here so the rosar crucian tradition
really began as completely independent
forms of initiation and by independent
what I mean by that is that the person
was an autonomous human being that did
not have any other human being who was
over them as a guru or a director of
that kind person was completely
autonomous and their connection for the
initiation was literally straight above
the head in the vertical axis of energy
that runs from high above us enters into
the Crown Center goes through the
midline of the human body out the
perineum down into the Earth there's
many different energy flows and axes in
the human body but this is the most
important of all of them and so many of
the most Advanced Techniques have to do
with learning not only how to activate
areas of our own brain and Consciousness
to be able to be more conscious and to
work through many things but also to be
able to put our attention above the head
and to be able to activate the centers
above the head in subsequent stages I
have an online course about activating
the stages above the head which is
called connecting to spiritual realities
it's very hard to find information on
that particular particular part of
things but again this is part of the
larger classical context and so the
rosac crucians in my view the real
Rosicrucianism the original
Rosicrucianism isn't in any external
physical organization again if people
want to create those and work within
that and it helps them God bless you but
I'm just saying that my particular
Prejudice is toward the original form
where everyone is autonomous and free
which is where we're going anyway
there's been a huge movement toward that
in the last hundred years
uh just historically now we have
millions and millions of people on a
free spiritual path we now have more
people on the free spiritual path in
most industrialized countries than we
have in any specific religious tradition
it's just it's it's an incredible change
in human history and so the rosar
crucian tradition is actually preparing
for this back in the 1600s for that
independent form of spiritual initiation
so one of the great teachers of this an
external teacher that actually came
forward and began to teach uh was
Rudolph Steiner yeah and so Rudolph
Steiner made the statement that that all
advanced spiritual initiation today by
and large is actually independent
initiation people being able to connect
directly to Spirit and someone else on a
similar path to you can be kind of an
elder brother or sister on the path they
may have gone farther than you and but
they don't they don't tell you what to
do that would be a violation of a
person's spiritual Freedom you never get
told what do by some external authority
figure you example being like what would
be being told what to do go like do a
sacrifice or if you join any spiritual
religion any religion or many spiritual
Traditions it's like a very crafted out
thing okay you got to do this you can't
do that it's like all these rules and
regulations about this is how your
path's going to run okay yeah sure it
could be just going to church at a
certain time and then you do this during
the ceremony you stand up and you kneel
or you do that or you go here and you do
this and as opposed to your own you're
talking about your own sort of
navigation naturally through you know
what your intuition energy and even what
the universe brings you is just sort of
leading you on the path it's far more
organic and it's led by you and you and
you exactly because what you find very
often is when when anybody teaches like
here's how you advance spiritually then
it's going to often come down to these
are the things I found were useful for
me and in my particular form of internal
structure that's what makes sense to me
and works for me but you may be giving
that somewhat hardened or rigidified
structure you must do this you can't do
that type of thing to someone who
doesn't have the same type of structure
and may not have the same Destiny they
may not be developing the same faculties
in their Consciousness and energy to do
the things they're meant to do that you
are so that's why we can learn from a
tremendous number of of people but it
really comes down to a combination of
contextual understanding now if you're
going to follow just like One external
religion and that's fine if that's what
you choose to do or one particular
spiritual tradition then you don't
necessarily have to understand
everything and in many of those cases
they don't explain a lot to you and
sometimes they're even hostile to
questions I've seen that in many
spiritual Traditions you start question
this exactly but again I find that's not
only true in certain religions it's very
true in some Modern spiritual Traditions
or groups as well if you start
questioning things they don't they're
not very happy about it and so damn youo
it's it's so much easier then for a
person to just join a group that's going
to tell them what to do where there's an
authority figure above them that says do
this don't do that type of thing you're
giving your will over to them to a
certain extent I don't want to over rep
play this if people want to do this
that's fine but we need to understand
what's at stake when you make that
choice I think is the key thing that's
not being discussed today in
metaphysical circles let's just be clear
that there's there's ramifications of
the choice that you make so ramification
point the ramification of the choice
that you make if you're giving your
power over to another human being that
you're giving that authority of a guru
to is that you're going to be taking on
whatever is their system and if that's
not the optimal thing for your structure
your purpose then you're kind of caught
into somebody else's trip I was I was
having a conversation about this just so
people can kind of like hear from my
perspective as an example like I was
talking to somebody about the spiritual
path essentially and really to know more
about yourself to find more happiness
and joy to get more into alignment you
know just to enrich in your life and I
said I'm pretty sure because there's no
path you can't just tell someone go do
this go do that you can say what's been
the most helpful for you but but I said
I'm pretty sure that for me it feels
like your interest in wanting to know
yourself and know more and growing
spiritually
is that's that that's it that is the
path and then you kind of let things
sort of come to you or you get led to
something but just wanting to know and
then you're open to all the paths and
all the ways that it could go you know
it's not a book it's not a practice it's
not a regimen
it's like I just want to know myself and
I want to know more about the world and
how it works and I want to grow I want
to
evolve yes so I want to be even-handed
with this I totally agree with what
you're saying but to be evenhanded I
want to clarify that the advantage of
following the classical method of I'm in
a specific tradition I'm going to be
there the rest of my life I'm going to
follow one grade after another one
degree after another whatever their
system is
is the advantage of it is what's often
described by people that support these
systems coming from a I think it's an
old Indian saying that uh you know if
you dig a lot of shallow holes meaning
if you look into a lot of different
Traditions but you don't do much with
them then you'll never find water just
digging a bunch of shallow holes if you
dig one hole and go deep then you'll
find the water which is the actual
spiritual Essence and transformation
you're looking for okay so that that's
that's the argument on that side that
particularly for people that don't have
a good contextual understanding if
there's some person or group that they
find trustworthy and that they resonate
with then following their directions for
everything can potentially lead to going
deep in One Direction that leads to
actually achieving quite a few things
spiritually so many people do achieve
things on that type of path M but I'm
just saying that's not that's not my
path but that is a path so again be
aware that the benefit of it could be
that you actually do achieve something
because it's they've had time to figure
it out and this path does
this uh the downside is that they may
not teach you absolutely essential
things that you need to learn for your
very different needed form of subtle
body structure and the things that
you're going to move toward in life and
they may have all types of
embedded things within their social
norms that aren't things that you want
to be restricted by so that's that's
that's one side of it the other side of
it is that on the independent path the
benefit of it is that you're able to
understand the actual effect of any
practice from any tradition doesn't mean
you can't do the practices from
different Traditions you can do
practices from any tradition but you
have the challenge of the independent
path is you have to have contextual
understanding of what particular
practices create what effects on the
mind and the body and they're doing that
by structuring the subtle bodies in a
particular
way and so the independent path requires
a lot more investment of time and energy
to be able to understand things
independently because now you're not
giving your power away to somebody else
who you think understands more than you
and is going to guide you because they
understand more than you do
you're bringing yourself up to the point
that you have to understand more to make
informed decisions that are going to
literally affect your
destiny when you reach your destiny
Point sooner or later whether you follow
what the Buddhist would call skillful
means and get there with the minimum of
suffering and the least amount of time
or unskillful means where you learn
through the School of Hard Knocks and
get hit around a lot because you didn't
figure it out correctly but it does
require you to really understand things
contextually to a deep level to make an
informed decision yeah yeah I'm going to
use a dumb example this is like um going
on a cruise and it's all set up for you
and you go to these stops and you might
not like them all might like some of
them or you go okay I'm gonna go to that
area but I'm going to plan it out I'm
going to find all the right spots the
right cities the right hotels the right
uh the right activities and it's totally
Cura it takes way more time than just
signing up for the cruise that has all
the stops set on it you might still have
a good time on the cruise but you're
going to know that you are you you're
going to be well informed when it comes
to the one that you pick every stop
that's my dumb example now that's a
great example because then you might
find that there's and this is very true
when you're traveling if you just stay
on the major parts of the tourist travel
route you'll never see the most
incredible hidden things that the locals
know about but that they're not going to
direct you to as just a tourist moving
through so that deeper contextual
understanding allows you to find the
most critical things on that pilgrimage
that you're you're going on it makes it
a pilgrimage rather than just an
entertainment that doesn't lead to
anything so for me I've always had an
orientation toward that independent path
so it does require a certain level of
spiritual maturity it does require a lot
more investment of time and energy and
you have to take the responsibility for
the outcome before you can put that
responsibility on somebody else as like
oh that you know they told me to do that
and it didn't work out it's their fault
but at a certain point of growing up as
an adult you get tired of blaming other
people and but you to get to that point
you're no longer blaming other people
you got to take responsibility onto
yourself if things are not working out
in your life and that's certainly true
when it comes to Spiritual Development
so bringing us all back to our main
topic here of the rosar crucian
tradition although many people adapted
Rosicrucianism into organizations where
you could join and you could go through
grad and this type of thing and many
people may benefit from that again I
think by and large the movement today is
for people to have independent forms of
initiation and that was very much set
forth as a pattern by the rosac crucian
tradition back when it became public
back in the early 1600s so I do want to
make this clear to people because I find
it's very rarely made clear when people
talk about rosac Cru and tradition like
oh where is it I want to join it it's
like let me send in my membership it's
like well you can find somebody that's
running a rose Cru organization and you
can do that and you become a member of
something but I I just want to emphasize
that from my perspective that's fine if
you do that that's not the key thing the
key thing is not Rosicrucianism that's
not what the that's not what this is
it's not core Rosicrucianism because
core Rosicrucianism requires you to be
independent this is my perspective yes
to directly connect to Spirit not go
through a human intermediary give the
power away to a human
intermediary and in that path you will
necessarily have to become extremely
conscious of all kinds of non-physical
realities that other people are not
because to connect when we talk about
this as something literal it's not
metaphoric you're literally connecting
up the column of energy above the head
to specific energy centers that give you
the capacity to perceive and have a
communication with non-physical beings
and to perceive non-physical realities
Rudolph Steiner referred to this as
Clairvoyance as a kind of control
psychosis and so it may not even be that
safer path for person who has serious
mental issues people who are psychotic
or yeah bipolar that might not be a they
need to like get stability in their
Earthly life before they try to tackle
something like this because if you're
perceiving non-physical things right now
but it's coming from a a state that is
yeah bad brain chemicals uh that might
you don't have the physical Foundation
to do this in a grounded and healthy way
so it requires
being fairly well grounded and well
adjusted to to take on this independent
path but we have to Simply accept the
fact we have to just acknowledge the
historical reality that the time we live
in now is when millions and millions of
people are voting with their feet to go
this direction it simply hasn't been
clearly delineated I don't think in
modern metaphysics the the the the
choice here between the organizations
because within modern metaphysics we
still have all these different gurus and
teachers and
organizations but the difference between
that and the independent path that's
that's a whole thing so the rosac
crucian tradition in its original form
that I believe in its true form is all
about a modern form of independent
initiation now that doesn't mean you're
doing it by yourself but it means that
the authority that you're working with
is not on the physical plane right it is
literally spiritual okay and so this
requires the ability to start
perceiving but again using a great piece
of terminology by Dr sagon from the
Clear Vision school he called packed
thought forms because in our physical
lives in the physical body we process
thoughts through the Machinery of the
physical brain but the human higher
Consciousness is not brain oriented in
fact there's even been brain research
like the work of Sir John Eckles who won
a uh no prized for his brain research
decades ago and he said I look for the
place that initiated the firing of
neurons that created a thought in the
human brain and I found there wasn't any
it actually comes from a higher
holographic field of energy around the
human head that then interacts as a
field of energy with the brain to
initiate the firing of neurons that Halo
in all the ancient photos it exactly
what it is and this is someone who won
the Nobel Prize for brain research
saying this so we have to get to the
point then that we start working at the
energy centers above the head quite
consciously and that allows us to start
working with packed thought forms so the
pack thought
forms are
essentially where it is the pure content
of Mind substance of the thought
substance itself it can be transmitted
in the form of images in the form of
sounds in the form of direct internal
kinesthetic knowing okay is thises
basically is this the clear audient
clear sentient clear exactly okay clear
cogniz the key thing is that it doesn't
have to get reduced from that direct
perception immediate knowing State into
words because word thinking is extremely
powerful on the physical plane it's a
type of digital thinking it's extremely
binary and so thinking in words is a
lower form of thinking and
communication people who have done any
type of Zen meditation vasana
Transcendental Meditation they'll
understand what I'm talking about higher
Consciousness states are not based on
thinking one word after another it's not
what they call the monkey mind shatter
it like comes to you it's like arrives
as a pack thought is that that's the
pack yes it does because you you don't
have to actually take the linear time
that you would hear to know the
information it all arrives at the same
time and it's like an awareness to
something new or an idea that's how it
feels to me it's like it's not like
somebody says the words this you're
going to do this and feel like how about
it's more like and it almost is paired
with the it's a it's it's it also is
like locks into almost like an
embodiment as well there's it's a it's
an actual experience on more levels than
just the words and thinking it's like a
whole full it's a full experien body
mind soul the whole thing it's it
becomes a knowing absolutely it's a type
of immediate transmission yeah that
leads to an immediate knowing and
reception so this is what they call
things like Transmissions like in the
Indian tradition like when the you're
getting the shocky transmission it's an
instantaneous transmission and so a Pac
thought form is the most condensed form
of the direct knowing of that thing it
gets transmitted in instant so this is
that Eureka moment where you get the
download in an instant and you get the
whole thing if you had to describe to
somebody else the information you
received in that moment yeah it could
take you days of trying to unpack it one
word after another and there you're
still not going to be able to fully
convey in the unpacked Words which take
forever to get out totally the direct
experience totally so to be able to
receive the pack thought forms is
essential to be able to have direct
communic
with non-physical beings and
non-physical realities because that's
how they communicate beings that are not
on the physical and we're surrounded by
them all the time this is something that
is like one of the very weird things
about the current state of humanity that
we're like I often use the example that
we're like fish in a in a sea that we're
surrounded by water but we don't know
water exists the water is this the
spiritual World we're embedded in the
spiritual world but if we don't have the
eyes to see it we have develop the
internal organs of perception we'll
never know that we're surrounded by
Spiritual Beings all the time that are
conveying information to us and those
Spiritual Beings are of varying levels
of reliability just like human beings
are and quality exactly so you have to
just like you have to have some
discernment with the company you keep on
the physical plane you have to have
discernment of The Company You Keep in
the non-physical world it's not a naive
I'm just opening up to any old thing
that wants to come in and type of thing
it's like you need to talk to the the
reliable beings and there's different
ways to differentiate that when we get
in that's a different topic but that's a
very important idea that we need to
develop the capacity to receive the pack
thought forms from the higher beings
where they can give us a lot of
information in a second I so again
that's nonverbal verbal is a lower level
for us to be able to communicate it by
breaking it down into bits but it's
super slow in comparison and it can be
super frustrating to be able do that
people who are good speakers are good
speakers because they've learned how to
receive or to hold pack thought forms
and to be able to bring it in a constant
Trail into the unpacking in the brain to
form words which then they can make some
sense out of it to be able to convey to
other people that's actually what's
happening behind the scenes when someone
was able to speak extemporaneously in a
in a eloquent manner that would be you
well I appreciate that I'm working on it
that's all I can ever say is I'm working
on it you so good at it well thank you
but I want people to understand the
principle behind it I mean that's the
whole idea of spiritual initiation we're
not just going to see the results of
things we want to understand the causes
of things we want to see what actually
creates that thing so you understand the
path so let's look at another aspect now
that we've talked about this as
Rosicrucianism being originally a
independent path and about developing
your Consciousness to be able to do
things like directly perceive
non-physical realities because that's
the real initiators M you know in some
traditions they just want to unify it
into the One Source behind everything
and so it's like God is the initiator
that's the one that's the totality of
everything other Traditions will then go
into the specific beings you're working
with because usually if somebody says
and many people get upset with me when I
say this but this is my perspective if
somebody says oh God told me this or God
told me that it's like well God is the
totality of all beings and all existence
in all universes known and unknown and
he told you that in physical words I was
like well maybe but my perspective is
that no if you got that and it wasn't
something you made up you actually got
it there's another being at another
level of existence you got it from and
so if you're going to deal with this in
a brass tax manner then I don't just
like meet somebody on the street and
somebody says oh where did you hear you
know that this band is playing at this
show I don't say oh told me because yeah
in a sense God told me because God
created that being right but yeah but if
I say God told me that Iron Maiden is
playing in Las Vegas next year well
that's a little weird but as a specific
individual that told me this and there's
usually specific individual beings that
are communicating things to you so
that's another thing that's extremely
important this has to become like part
of one's lived reality but it has you
can't even do it unless you're able to
have such a
such equinity such balance that being
able to perceive non-physical realities
doesn't throw you off your Center you
know you don't have what the jbed call
grasping which like oh that's
fascinating I see this non-physical
being or thing and you try to grasp it
soon as you do that you'll corrupt it
you have to stay completely calm and
just observe it at the same time you
don't shrink away from it you may
receive things about horrible things
that happened to you in past
incarnations you may receive something
about something horrible that's going to
happen to you this Incarnation very hard
to have equinity about that but that's
the only way to not corrupt what you
perceive spiritually ah yeah you've
exper it's experienced in meditation I
feel like or even like a dream feels
like you do it where you're trying to go
back into it you're like you're in a
meditation and you're like oh that's
cool and you're like you're like you
start to realize something and you're
like you try and look harder essentially
and then it disappears or like in the
you wake up sort of and you think that
was a great dream and I like okay what
was I thinking about again and then you
can't get there again it just disappears
it won't come to you and it's in the
surrender that you actually are now able
to perceive there's no you've got to
open instead of close and narrow that's
that's what it feels like to me that
I've had the experiences of that's ABS I
absolutely agree with you that's exactly
how it works again to take a a phrase
from Dr San at the Clair Vision school
he would often say I thought this was a
brilliant summary that your ability to
received spiritually is governed by your
ability to not react to What you
see yeah that is absolute core of
everything so you know in all types of
personal development work one of the
first things we do in psychological
self-help or personal development work
is that we understand we have to get
beyond the reactive mind the reactive
mind is your enemy the reactive mind
makes you a a beast it reduces you to
the level of an animal functioning in
the bad sense of that term and and
you're not at a truly human stage you're
just an input output mechanism you're a
machine I can push this button with you
and you're going to react this way
because you're just so deeply programmed
you can't even see your programming
right and so we have to understand that
we have to get past the reactive mind to
do any of this otherwise what people
think they're seeing clairvoyantly is
nothing other than the projection of
their own mind substance and of their
own weird crap so this is another
important part of the
independent path of spiritual initiation
because there are various trials on the
path whether you do it with a group and
you give your power over to an external
teacher or you do it in the independent
path there's going to be what's known
classically as trials as challenges and
they have to be there people just say oh
I don't want to have to deal with those
let's just get rid of them that doesn't
work that way the only way that you
develop the skill that you develop the
ca is by going through the trial and
succeeding in it and it will keep coming
up until you can you can pass it often
in multiple lifetimes you'll keep
getting these horrible experiences until
finally you figure out how to get
through it and then you don't have to
keep going through it anymore it's like
a grade of school that you got to get
through and so this whole idea that we
need to be able to overcome certain
challenges one of the first challenges
that you have on the path and
particularly this is true on the
independent path it's also true on the
path of the organization but very much
on the independent path is one of the
very first challenges is is ego
inflation that you think that you're way
more advanced than you are and you set
up your own little spiritual group and
you're the guru and you're the teacher
and you're perfect and you know
everything and you got all this power
and it's this ego inflation happens very
quickly on the path and we see it
everywhere in metaphysics today you know
humility isn't the
group now you can be a you can be a
teacher you can have a group but it's
not a matter that you know you've
reached some perfected State and give
yourself you start giving yourself High
titles and that type of thing rather
than being Joe Blow then that's usually
a sign that something's going on here
you start and one of the things for the
rosar crusan to avoid this is that
you're not allowed in
Rosicrucianism now again we say you know
being told what to do what not to do
this is a
suggestion on the independent path
you can do anything you want but you
know some things just don't make sense
you know you could choose to be a heroin
addict but probably that won't make
sense in the long run and one thing that
won't make sense and usually goes wrong
in the long run is when people start
talking publicly about their past
incarnations and so it's like well I was
the great soand so and I did this and I
did that that usually attracts the wrong
type of attention and it usually usually
goes bad everybody was something great
in past lives of course that's and don't
believe me ask them exactly ask me I
mean I trust me I mean and it also leads
to people getting all this ego
attachment to who they were before and
again I don't want to offend anybody but
I have literally met over a dozen
reincarnations of Mary Magdalene it's
like such a common thing today for
people to think they are The
Reincarnation of Mary Magdalene or that
they were one of the Disciples of Christ
or they were this or that here's here's
a great marker for evaluating these
experiences if you actually were these
people like let's say a disciple of
Christ or something like that your
memory of it is often going to be a
somatic memory of suffering it's not
going to be like I so great I'm so
Advanced I'm this amazing person follow
me listen to me anytime people talk like
that it's nothing but dealing with their
own core wounds and compensating for
inferiority complexes otherwise you'd
never do that crap I mean there's
uh but the people experienced on that
the people that were disciples around
Christ they didn't have like some
fantastic I'm an elevated person thing
they were trudging around in the desert
in sandals barely with enough to eat or
drink and constantly under threat of
torture and death I mean these were hard
experiences so when people have you know
have I was a great so and so people that
were the great so and so they know the
suffering that came in that lifetime
they know the the what they went through
to be able to do what they did at that
time and they also they feel that's it
took to be
remembered that that they there's no
they don't want to talk about it
publicly it gets the wrong type of
attention people aren't going to
understand it the way it actually was
it's going to be sensationalized and
romanticized and so again the challenge
is ego inflation and so there's
suggestions in rosar Cru I'm like don't
start talking about your past
incarnations or that can go really wrong
but also just the whole idea that you're
way more advanced than you actually are
you know all you got to do is like look
at look at your romantic relationships
and usually that'll bring you down hard
and fast no I don't want to did that I
had multiple therapists for a while I
feel like I kind of bridged the Gap not
saying it's gone but let's not talk
about it exactly but that's the kind of
thing that when you deal with family
when you deal with people in Intimate
Relationships they'll bring you down
fast to the fact that you're not perfect
and you haven't figured it all out yet
so
so this is another aspect of the thing
of the independent path there are
certain trials and don't get caught up
in in the things like inflating your ego
just because now you can hear people's
thoughts and you can do these other
things that other people can't do okay
it's almost always a mistake even to
talk about it I mean most people are not
going to take well if you let them know
like oh yeah I can hear your thoughts
well most people that's not going to
work out well in most cases now you're
not trying to do it there are ways that
there are esoteric methods you can use
to penetrate into a person's head and to
get the thoughts but that's a type of
invasion uh but there's a natural method
that just by clarifying your own
thoughts so you have a completely clear
mind you start hearing other people's
thoughts just because you're quiet
enough to hear them people are
broadcasting them like they're shouting
all the freaking time that's all we're
doing that's why sensitive people have a
hard time often being in like chaotic
environments right because it's just
like people are shouting mentally all
the time and it's like you're feeling
their weird energies so
so now let me talk about uh uh some
other aspects on the path there's also
the idea in the rosac crucian tradition
that there are certain types of
initiation maxims again let's call them
suggestions for ways to develop in a
healthy way one of them is to make the
decision at the very beginning of the
work that you do that all the spiritual
powers and understanding that you gain
on the path will be put to the service
of other
people not as an abstract thought but as
something so deep in your heart and your
gut that it's a way of life that you're
going to put these things that you
develop to the service of other people
it's first service now this is one of
the things that when you start seeing
the group of beings that are behind
let's say Buddhism working with all the
initiates of Buddhism the group of
beings behind Christianity Christ
archangels High Saints Masters Etc that
you would be connected to that as you go
up let's say a level or two
you find that the beings behind
Christianity and behind Buddhism start
to get a lot of overlap there's a
tremendous amount of overlap between the
beings behind Buddhism and Christianity
which have to do with teachings of
compassion and love and non- revenge
non- anger things like this things that
have to do with developing beyond the
animal reactive stage well then we got
to say that Taylor Swift is probably not
one of those people talks about uh
vigilante and revenge and
reputation yeah yeah not Taylor Swift
got it well one thing I always want to
make sure to do is to leave the the
space of Grace open for people that but
whenever you know I always whenever a
celebrity like we have a kind of thing
where we like to to like uh build up
celebrities and then we tear them down
and I think oh that's probably not a
healthy way to it so my whole thing is
that even when celebrities are doing
crazy things that are not not the great
role model for for other people because
they're just people going through their
lives too that in a karmic pathway that
could transform to something completely
different yeah it's true and so you
always just want to hold in your heart
for somebody like well that anger is a
natural human stage revenge is a natural
stage of the path and so we see the
stage that's being passed through right
now and you're making it visible but I
really hope you get to the next stage
because you'll be a lot more comfortable
when you get there oh yeah way I try way
I try to look at it that's a nice way
that's a nice way to put some frosting
on it on the top of that and and be very
positive I like that yeah yeah we always
have to have compassion when people are
acting out publicly and it just shows
that they're in a particular stage of an
alchemical path got it and the later
stages are on the way and and I really
hope that you get to them sooner rather
than later for relieving your own
suffering because that's like one of the
great gifts of the Buddhist thing is
that when somebody hurts you somebody
does something terrible to you
somebody's not a good person and has
really harmed you the first thing you
look at is how they're suffering how
they're acting out from their suffering
whether they don't they may not even
know their suffering but it's really a
reaction to it yeah and that's the way
the Buddhists get a get past anger it's
a it's a beautiful system and it's the
exact same thing in Christianity because
this is related to what was the
Christian initiation esoteric system
before the rosac crucians because before
we had Rosicrucianism going public
around their 1600s you had before that
the Holy Grail tradition in Christianity
that began around the 9th century and
the text for that was the the the epic
poem
parsible and in there the The Grail
lesson The Grail question that parsel
has to learn is to ask brother or sister
what ails thee and so brother or sister
what ails thee is the exact same thing
in as in Buddhism in asking how does the
person suffer to get past anger and to
understand the person and see how you
can help the person and so that just
shows you again an overlap of these
Traditions now the point I want to make
here then is that I consider myself to
be an aspirant toward the rosac crucian
tradition there's a I always think of
this this beautiful response that Bono
from You2 gave in an interview
many years ago like in the 80s when he
was being interviewed about being a
Christian and uh you know he was talking
a lot about that at the time and
somebody says do you consider yourself a
Christian and Bono's response was I
would hesitate to give myself that high
a
compliment and that's the way I feel
about rosac crism someone says are you
rosac crucian I would hesitate to give
myself that high a compliment I aspire
to it I do my best with that
I try to share what I understand and
have experienced with that with other
people but again we have to be very
careful of ego inflation yeah people
start saying I am the representative of
this tradition and blah blah blah blah
because ultimately it's an ongoing
process I would imagine there's actually
not really there's not an end to it so
to say you've arrived somewhere is
completing it and there's really no
completion it's like it's a it's a life
practice of of a it's a life practice it
really is and you can always fall back
from a state as well sure in a free will
Universe this because you've attained
something doesn't mean you're G to hold
on to it now this is you're gonna have
your own entropy there that's right
that's why there's a very important
concept here that I like to talk about I
don't see specifically in rosar crism
but I think it would belong to it in the
sense that it's such a core spiritual
principle which is that we have certain
stages of activity and today everybody
talks about healing and everything is
about healing but it's often dealt with
as an healing is like a goal in itself
and that's not really the case healing
is meant to make us whole the term heal
comes from the root
whole and so people get caught up in
healing and I found years ago that if I
teach a class and I put the word healing
in the title I'll get three times the
number of people if I don't as if I
don't put the word healing in the
title but it becomes like a thing we're
like constantly healing and I'm not
saying that's a bad thing it's
absolutely essential because we have to
become whole enough to do what we came
here to do because one of the things so
you're saying it's not healing it's more
of like Illuminating or merging or what
you're pointing toward is that there's
later stages healing is just stage one
but people aren't always clear what
comes after the healing just like I'm
I'm always healing I'm constantly
healing and yes that's true we are but
the fact that we're constantly focusing
just on healing it's like we're
forgetting what healing is for why are
we becoming whole why are we wanting to
get all of our our act together in the
first place yeah and because the whole
spiritual path is around remembering who
am I why am I here and what did I choose
to do in this
Incarnation because life is a limited
time opportunity and extremely limited
time opportunity for us to achieve
certain things in our Spiritual
Development yeah and so we have to keep
our eyes on the prize so after we get
enough healing we have to make sure that
we don't just keep focusing I'm going to
do more healing and more healing and
more healing yes keep doing more healing
keep finding new and better ways to heal
but start focusing the majority of your
attention on what that's for and so the
next stage above that is activation you
need to activate your Consciousness you
need to activate your heart forces you
need to activate your will you need to
activate your perception of who am I why
am I here what did I incarnate to do so
yes healing is very very important but
it's not the end in itself you want to
do that so you can activate inside of
every person our latent Powers again
what they call CS in in India that
activate our Consciousness activate our
heart forces activate our will forces
bring online hidden powers and
potentials and understandings and
skills that we all developed in previous
lifetimes
that may not be fully back yet in this
lifetime and to activate things so we
can generate brand new skills yeah and
things we've never had before yeah to to
integrate into our course structure but
that's not the end in itself either
because many people will be able to get
activations particularly when they are
assisted by things like there's a huge
revolution in psychotropics now and I'm
doing a lot of work with the
psychotropics community and I'm I'm a
supporter of that but again we always
have to have
a uh balanced perspective on it and so
it's very possible the person will have
some type of trip or something and and
they'll get activated but the question
is can you hold it in a way that serves
your totality and preserves it going
forward because it's possible to get all
of these activations but can you
integrate it into your core structure so
that you then
stay at that level of development and
then can add more to it so there has to
be stability to it so that's why above
activation is then
stabilization you have to stabilize the
states so one thing that I'm trying to
get to understood in the psychotropic
Community is do some healing work
sometimes on core things yeah before you
do massive amounts of the psychotropics
because then it's going to go a lot
better when you do if some of that
stuff's already dealt with MH otherwise
it's just going to come up for you to
process and if you've taken a quantity
of a substance that you're not riding
the wave but the wave is crashing on you
like a 100 foot wave in in Hawaii then
that might not be skillful action yeah
in the way to to do this it might be a
better way to go about it right but once
you've got the activated State don't
just assume oh I'm going to be
enlightened for the rest of my life it's
you have to find a way to stabilize it
and this is this is a literal thing it
has to be stabilized in the energy body
has to be stabilized in the structures
of the subtle body stabilizing the
structures in the subtle body is
something that's not hardly discussed at
all today yeah you're this is new I'm
very curious what you mean by this and
like as as an example what would that
what would be needed to do that so A a
very simple example of it is every time
that you use your mind in a certain way
you are structuring the energy patterns
in your head in a very specific geom
omry in a very specific shape you're
activating certain parts of the brain
and you're sedating other parts of the
brain you're activating release of
certain types of neurochemicals based on
the the quality of what you're thinking
and you're doing and other types of
stress chemicals in the body Etc It all
becomes a pattern that has a geometric
form to it in your body of what things
are activated and what's deactivated
same thing with the heart you find some
people have massively expanded heart
energy other people people have almost
none why because of the way that they've
been using their heart energy the
attention they're giving to it anybody
can change that at any time but we need
to be aware that one of the saying is
thoughts are things and we need to be
aware that every thought that you have
every feeling and emotion you have every
action you take they are all causes set
in motion they all have an energetic
basis to them they will all activate
certain things in your body of energy
and when you do it over time time that
will then create a pattern in the energy
body that then becomes your state your
mental state your emotional state your
ability to take action in a destructive
or a beneficial way biological State
exactly but I mean we could actually see
this so when a clairvoyant perceives
someone's energy field they can see oh
this person has a very activated third
eye center but the center above it may
not be as activated so they're capable
of some things here but they're not
capable of what these things do and
maybe their their heart is suppressed
that may be leading if you go back to
the healing level might go back to the
fact that now they have heart problems
because the way they've been using their
emotions is actually destroying the
function biological function of the
heart because it's a cause set emotion
and it is creating an energy vibrational
broadcast that's actually harming their
physical heart in addition to not having
a stable structure to the to the whole
energy body so anyway this is something
that we rarely hear about today it's
extremely important something that Dr
Sagan emphasized a lot of the Clair
Vision school but really is a classical
understanding what is the structure of
our subtle bodies and we need to
activate it to higher levels so that our
mind our heart our will centers the
three primary centers of the energy body
are all activated and working together
in an optimal way and that we can
stabilize that so that we can hold that
so that you know when we use
psychotropic substances things of that
kind it introduces us to a state and
just like in neurolinguistic programming
can we entrain to that state to be able
to hold it without having to continue
doing the substance every week or
something now you may need to do it on a
particular basis until the pattern gets
set but again what we're trying to do is
we're trying to integrate this and we're
trying to hold it Norm or yeah try to
hold it over a longer period of time now
if I can segue into another topic with
the the time we there's another very
important thing I want to make people
aware of that's not often discussed with
Rosicrucianism and that's to understand
that rosac crism is the current
manifestation of an ancient tradition
which took other forms in earlier times
just as we take on different forms in
different lifetimes I may have looked
very different and acted quite
differently 3,000 years ago in Egypt
than I do today you know we take
different forms based on the culture and
on on whatever it is that we and
Humanity as a whole is working to
crystallize at this particular time if
the rosac crucian tradition came on in
the early 1600s what was it before then
well before then it connected to what
was called the Holy Grail tradition in
Europe and at that time people
incarnated in the south of France and
were part of the bogam mils
Albans the cathars all these things that
were murdered all these groups Holy
Grail groups that were murdered by the
Pope's armies and were part of this
whole uh marry lineage in the south of
France that we often hear about today
but it even started even before that
with what happened around the court of
Charlemagne with the beginning of the
Holy Grail tradition the writing of the
Epic thorm parsible it was a way to
crystallize the new form of spiritual
initiation for the forms that people
could understand in their current
culture and and with an understanding of
the initiation trials they have to get
through right now because we may have
gone through different initiation trials
in uh back at the time of ancient Egypt
or things of that kind you're struggling
with something else it's a different
point in history so you might need
something else as a way to deal with
life and yes it's it's essentially a
consecutive series of uh stages in an
alchemical process
oh so as we keep moving through this
alchemical process for a lot of people
we go back to Egypt so I I meet so many
people today who have a resonance with
ancient Egypt who often remember being
in ancient Egypt and have often
connections between each other from
ancient Egypt now this is the foundation
of then of what we called the Hermetic
tradition and the Hermetic tradition we
should be aware is something that opens
you up to working with every source of
knowledge every tradition that's what
hermeticism is that you take spiritual
wisdom from every place it comes from
and as an independent act as as your own
authority you're able to synthesize it
into these are broken fragments of a
complete teaching this tradition got
this part this tradition got this part
we can bring it back together and now we
have the picture of what the exact
reality of spiritual reality and
physical reality and their connections
are so that's something that we in our
current understanding we take back to
ancient Egypt with the Hermetic
tradition but that also became a
foundation for the rosac crucian
independent path that I'm talking about
right now that's been worked on for a
long time it didn't just happen we'd
worked on for a long time in ancient
Egypt we didn't follow a purely
independent path there were aspects of
it we were we were being trained for it
to come at a later time but but we were
part of a temple and you were got
trained in the temple and there was a
very hierarchical structure and things
of that kind because that's the way that
the society at the time and our stage of
alchemical development could do the
process most
effectively even then some of the most
active and Enlighten people like
Pythagoras could like go and train in
Egypt and train in Babylon and do this
kind of thing you know they could still
it still was possible but it wasn't the
mass movement that it is today wow so we
are an ongoing process so we have been
building on
this practice since absolutely and again
it took different forms if we try to
initiate someone in the Egyptian style
today with all of their cultural
conditions uh most people in modern
culture wouldn't even understand what
we're talking about because we don't
have the same cultural references and
we're not necessarily in the same stage
of of evolutionary development the same
alchemical stage now we can learn a lot
from it obviously with my teaching
biogeometry and my how gr much great
gratitude I have for working with Dr
Kareem Etc biogeometry is incredibly
important yeah but let's be clear Dr
kareim is bringing this rediscovered
knowledge that he was able to find
through his research from ancient Egypt
into a modern cultural context and a
modern format for what we have to deal
with right now like electromagnetic
fields they didn't have to deal with
that right 5,000 years ago in Egypt so
we have us to always see it in context
so there's a sac geometry of space and
that's what people tend to think of when
we say sacred geometry like platonic
solids and things you see in like
psychedelic imagery and these types of
things but there's also a sacred
geometry of time so we have to see the
pattern in time both in our own
lifetimes to understand who am I why am
I here but we also have to understand
the sacred geometry of time when it
comes to things like spiritual
Traditions which we may be associated
with in different lifetimes and the
whole evolution of humanity through
these Traditions so there's a c thread
here that if you read the original
teachings of the Greeks who went to
study in Egypt and came back like in the
Pythagorean school like the writings of
Plato says very directly that the Greeks
like Solon in the writings of Plato when
they talk to the Egyptian priests they
said all of our knowledge came from
Atlantis now today Atlantis is
considered to be some type of new agage
whooo fantasy whatever right they're
ignoring the fact it comes from
historical documents that are thousands
of years old of what the Egyptian
priests themselves told their initiates
that's where the whole word comes from
and so really we would have to go back
to the Atlantean times to understand
this trajectory there is an
understanding of some times before that
that according to the secret Doctrine
teachings of people like blaty and the
theosophist they have certain names very
ancient times of the polarian epoch the
hyperborean ETC fascinating stuff but
way too complex to get into here
conditions of form that we had very
different then but Atlantean we we can
still sometimes go back to that to
understand it so the Atlantean going
forward to the Egyptian many of us
having very formative experiences in
Egypt and there's the hidden sacred
geometry of time that in what's referred
to in Rosicrucianism as the post
Atlantean uh time period which is our
current Epoch the post Atlantean Epoch
everything that now that's what we're in
now that's a long period of time
and in the sacred geometry of time it's
divided into seven sections the number
seven is part of a rhythm that governs
time and so you know there's the first
stage after that and this is according
to the rosar crucian tradition first
stage after that was the ancient Indian
vdic tradition like literally the time
of the vadas was a founding in India of
people that left Atlantis at the time of
the destruction okay the founding of the
the civilization in the indis valley and
then that moved to the second period
which was the Persian zoroastrian period
it was at that time that they began to
perceive certain things spiritually that
had not been clearly perceived before
and this is where the religion of light
in Persia then the third Epoch was the
Egyptian caldan Babylonian and that was
the Egyptian Epoch then the next is the
Greco Roman Epoch that's the fourth
period and at that point you know the
Romans conquered the known world
sort of thing and they develop the
foundations for modern science
Etc then we move into the current Epoch
which is referred to as the European
Epoch in the rosac crusan tradition and
we can see that Europe became the
dominant force in that
Epoch and then the next one is going to
be the Eastern European Epoch the
Eastern European peoples will bring in
new impulses the way that these other
people brought in new impulses
culturally before and we're not there
yet we're not in the Eastern European
Epoch yet we're not there yet but it's
being formed If You observe certain
things happening in Eastern Europe it's
it's preparing for when that's going to
become a dominant and when we did this
we when I interviewed you before you
gave the manora as sort of like a
connection of time so is that exactly
that what you're alluding to with this
rosar crucian teaching of time exactly
because if you understand that that we
have these seven periods then
uh the manora that we described last
time wanted to bring it into context
with what we're describing right now so
we can understand where the
Rosicrucianism came from it came through
evolution of these
Traditions but we also have the aspect
of it that the manur is the the original
form like what they you see in the Arch
of Titus in Rome where they stole the
manora from the Temple of Solomon uh
around 70 AD with the Jewish revolt and
the Romans putting it down that you know
the manora they had in the temple of
Solomon it had a uh straight line coming
down support staff at the fourth place
where you put the fourth candle that's a
Greco Roman Epoch when you see it in
sacred geometric structure the third and
the fifth are connected in an
arc the second and the sixth and the
first and the seventh so the third Epoch
is the Egyptian Epoch the fifth epoch is
our current European so the reason why
many of us that had that Incarnation at
that time are so focused on Ancient
Egypt and I believe also another hidden
reason why Dr K is doing this
unbelievable work releasing what had
never been made public before about some
of the inner knowledge of the ancient
Egyptian temples within biogeometry work
has to do with the fact that we are
working with those impulses from the old
Egyptian time in a way that is mirror
imaged it's reversed that that fourth
place is like a a mirror and all the
earlier periods get reversed or Mirror
Image in going the opposite direction
that we went through
before and so there's a lot of things
now that we're working with what we
developed in the Egyptian Epoch and
we're now transforming it the essence of
that those Powers those abilities that
Essence into something that's at a
higher level at this current stage okay
so this then brings together uh type of
movement in the Traditions I just talked
about but also many people find in their
incarnations that they'll find there's
this Atlantean to Egypt to then for
quite a few people that then led into
working with the
ases uh in the Jewish tradition when the
Jews left Egypt because you know Moses
was initiated of the Egyptian temple and
there's a direct evolution of that
knowledge into the Jewish cabala much of
it came from the Egyptian temple then it
changed form for a different different
culture and so there's some incredible
stuff that happened in the AES that's
another discussion and then from there
it moves
into uh the Christian tradition into
Europe and what then developed with
aspects
of contemporaneous with the ases was the
Greek knowledge and how that developed
and then developing in Europe with
Christianity everything from the early
Christian centuries which was really
venting in Alexandria Egypt uh and
that's where the early Christian
writings that are the most advanced like
those coming from origin in Alexandria
Egypt in the thir century books like on
first principles they're mind-blowing
books most Christians don't even know
anything about these books but it's the
real metaphysical basis of the whole
thing and then it came into Europe
became the Holy Grail tradition
became the rosar crucian tradition and
so I wanted to make sure that as we had
this discussion today I could I could
show this and some people will find in
their own karmic biography as they
remember things like oh this is the the
pearls on the thread for for these two
incarnations but at the same time
there's a lot of richness in this uh
extract but there's also an aspect that
that doesn't mean that there weren't
also incarnations in other parts of the
world
so many people that have an innate
resonance with the rosar crucian
tradition will have memories of
incarnations in eastern traditions in
India China many other cultures because
there's a a tremendous amount of
knowledge there and that shows that they
are a part of the Hermetic tradition
they're a part of being able to access
spiritual Knowledge from all sources and
because in the deeper hidden aspect of
the rosac Cru tradition this is related
to the direct impulse coming from
Archangel Mikael Archangel Mikael is
known to the rosac crucians as the
Regent of the cosmic
intelligence and also known as The
Cosmopolitan Spirit what that means is
that he sounds cool yes Archangel Mikael
is the being that understands the
original nosis how all the original
knowledge that got broken up and
distributed in the different of the
world comes back into a unified
spiritual
science and that's why at the beginning
of the current age of Mikael beginning
in 1879 in the reign of The Seven
archangelic Ages a whole another sacred
geometry of time subject we are living
currently in the age of Mikel that's why
Rudolph Steiner as a very Advanced rosac
Cru initiate began to teach publicly
around the year 1900 and released
extremely Advanced rcru knowledge that
in kept very secret before for and why
we're getting this huge explosion now at
the turn of the last century of the
release of previously hidden information
from so many traditions because it's the
mikelic impulse to put back together the
complete nosis or the complete modern
spiritual science and to be honest to do
my little part toward that that's why
I'm here and why I created The vess
Institute to do my best to save people
time and energy to pull key pieces from
different bodies of work that would help
to make coherent
enough the practices principles Etc from
multiple directions to give them the
context where they could follow an
independent path of initiation and make
informed choices about what practices
and directions they want to go once they
start to remember who am I why am I here
that are going to help them to actualize
their potential and fulfill that path
it's not a matter of developing the way
that I've developed it's not a matter of
going to my particular trajectory it's a
matter of getting the pieces that you
need that's going to get you to your
place I I thought it would end up being
like here's the level one here's the
level two these are the courses but
there's so much more um fundamental
Integrity to the reason for the practice
it's a way of being it's rooted in so
much Integrity as to why you would go
down this path and and and it's uh and
it's a unique experience for each person
to some degree so there's not it's not
so obvious to just lay it out but if you
could sort of bring this together
to why would someone why would someone
practice this why would someone go into
the rosac Christian teachings and try
and learn about it like what is the goal
the fundamental reason for someone to
listen to this and go ah that makes
sense because until we remember who we
are why we're here what we chose to do
in this lifetime we are amnesiacs who
are wandering lost in the world not
knowing who we are why we're here and
not using the precious moments that are
ticking away in this lifetime for the
essential work that we must do to
develop spiritually along this path and
we will get caught in the path of
unskillful action and unnecessary
suffering until we take the path of
skillful action
and begin to work with this consciously
and begin to remember who we are and
take in our own hands the reign of our
Spiritual
Development so it really is a choice
between suffering or Spiritual
Development you can develop through the
path of the School of Hard Knocks much
longer much harder if that's your choice
to not wake up and continue to be an
amnesiac or you can take the path of
skillful action
and not only help yourself through that
but it will for the first time bring on
your full capacity to help other people
around you which is really that whole
moral core of Spiritual Development
particularly in the Christian and
Buddhist Traditions the more that we
develop ourselves the more we can
relieve the suffering of others as well
as our own
suffering and then what kind of world do
we live in do we live is it that our own
world changes is that we internally have
a different world so the way we perceive
everything around us changes so
essentially the world does change or is
it because the world itself actually
does change as a result of all of us
participating in the base frequency and
and and awareness that we all have as
human beings to something more you
stated it wonderfully and is as is so
often the case with these deep profound
questions it's usually not an either or
it's a both and and so it will totally
transform our own lives and our own
experience of Our Lives to something
much more pleasurable much more exciting
much more Rich by following this type of
path of
development but also when it can reach a
critical mass yeah it does transform the
world we need to take very seriously
today that the way that people lived
before the founding of the American
experiment and the writing of the
Declaration of Independence and the
Constitution was very much subject to
the whims of rulers in like grotesque
systems of governance around the world
forever now this been horribly perverted
in in modern times there's no doubt for
that but we have to see that what people
pulled off in the 1700s in creating a
self-governing constitutional system as
imperfect as it was has created
possibilities for us in our current
lifetime that are incredible so we've
done it before we've changed the world
system before and we can and will do it
again and seeing from a metaphysical
perspective this has been foreseen for a
tremendous period of time and it's
what's always been referred to as
creating the new golden age so to go
back to biogeometry in biogeometry when
we find what is a vibrational signal
that actually indicates the connection
to the Divine
plane some not as a metaphor but
something very real that then creates a
vibrational emanation as an energy field
on the physical plane that's connected
to that Universal harmonizing force that
we tap into in the biogeometry work that
one of the signals or markers of that
energy is literally what we call the
higher harmonic of gold when we connect
to the Divine when we connect to this
Universal harmonizing energy is
something very real not metaphoric we
create this gold Radiance the gold
radiance you see around the heads and
the bodies of the Saints and the so this
is where people talk about the Alchemy
and like turning things to
Gold what we're doing with this work is
Transforming Our Own energy field into
gold and then together reaching a
critical mass to transform the world we
live in into the new golden age it's
actually quite a literal description of
what we have as our task in front of us
if we can pull it off then we've passed
through this alchemical stage and we've
graduated to the next level if we fail
which is a very real
possibility then we're going to have to
go through quite a lot of unnecessary
suffering we have to go backwards to go
forwards again then or does it just take
longer yeah it will take longer but we
will go backwards because what happens
when civilizations fail is that they
collapse and people start living like
cavemen rather than in a modern
technological culture so there's a
certain movement backwards that is not
inevitable doesn't have to happen but
again whether we reach a new golden age
or we we descend into a new Dark Age is
all dependent upon how many people wake
up and transform our own lives and then
we can join together with this work and
there's a lot of good signs there's a
lot of terrible signs today too but
there's a lot of good signs today with
what's happening with people waking up
moving forward and wanting to improve
the conditions that we're in if we can
keep things like social media and free
exchange of ideas opinions Etc free and
not curtailed by governments the way
that they always choose to do we have a
very good chance the Hallmark of the
fact that we're going down the wrong
path is when governments are are going
to really crack down on the free
exchange of ideas and communication good
to know I was going to ask you if
there's any I I I I was imagining that I
would have there would you'd be able to
be able to change the weather and
manipulate
objects and energy and whatever else
but I don't know if that really matters
to even ask that seemed like part of the
I think that's a very I think there's a
very mature response to that because uh
all that is possible I have seen people
very Advanced who can change the weather
and did change the weather in front of
me it's very possible but if they have
any sense they never do it publicly and
they never talk about it publicly it
will lead to the worst type of attention
and the worst type of people trying to
tap into that power for the wrong
reasons right so all this happens
naturally as a development of Cs of
powers as a person develops along the
path but it's not the goal right it's
what happens as a natural consequence of
the expansion of consciousness and
energy okay thank you for getting my ego
in check
today I we all have to do that all the
time yes I really appreciate it I um
thank you I feel like we could do like
Danica and Robert the 20 part series yay
for now we'll just do interviews
whenever you say yes that sounds great
I'd love to but I loved that very very
deep and wide explanation from like the
real roots of rosac cruin and um also
what we talked about about biogeometry
and stem cells and all the fun stuff and
yes um there's just so much in this for
us to chew on
and get us ready for the go age
absolutely I so appreciate you having me
on the program I always love talking
with you because you have the power of
active listening and that's that's
absolutely vital to be able to pull out
the the deeper information I very much
appreciate you oh gosh well thank you so
much Robert you're just a wealth of
knowledge and I'm grateful for your time
thank you great thank you so much thanks
everybody for listening to the pretty
intense podcast today I hope you enjoyed
it if you like what you heard today and
you want to hear more please click on
the Subscribe
button